police shootings across the US have
increased concerns about race relations
in the country a recent Gallup poll
shows sixty four percent of Americans
worry about race relations that's up
more than 20 percentage points from 2014
among those concerned Americans are two
Republican lawmakers from South Carolina
Tim Scott senator Tim Scott and trey
Gowdy congressman from South Carolina
they believe their different backgrounds
can be an example of how our country can
come together their new book out today
is called unified how our unlikely
friendship gives us hope for a divided
country Senator Scott and congressman
Gowdy good morning to both of morning
John
I want to start with you you said your
friendship would not have even been
possible in the state of South Carolina
remind people why absolutely if you
think about Charleston specifically it's
the home of the Civil War or the start
of the Civil War think about Jim Crow
you think about the sixties you think
about racial polarization the
Confederate flag going up in the 60s you
don't think about a black guy and a
white guy coming together after a
racially motivated shooting at Emanuel
AME Church where my uncle attended for
50 years you think about that racially
rich and provocative past and you come
to the conclusion that America is on the
wrong road but what I've experienced in
South Carolina over the last several
decades is that the evolution of the
southern heart it is so powerful so
amazing that there is reasons to be
hopeful even with the backdrop of
tragedies in our nation today the
polarization is real but the hope is
eternal and after that shooting the
congressman was the first phone call you
made white congressman which i think
would have surprised a lot of people it
surprised me for you in retrospect one
of the reasons why unified is so
powerful for me is because the book
talks about the paradigm shift that
occurred in my own heart I was called
the n-word in high school I had some
real challenges and Trey on that
Wednesday evening about 10 o'clock I
called the white guy I didn't even know
before I came to Congress why'd you call
him because he had become the most
trusted confident that I had in a town
where you don't make friends if you want
a friend in DC by it
yeah you don't look to another person
and Trey was just he was there he walked
that road wins the evening with me he
attended the funeral and and some of the
wakes he was a powerful force anchoring
me during a time where I just thought
the tragedies are back again and this is
just a couple months after the Walter
Scott police I remember that also in
also angers also in your state yes but
this is what Tim says about you Trey I
know you've read the book he says you've
got a great advice and thank you for
reading but I thought I was very touched
he said that you are that you give great
advice and that you are naturally
brilliant congressman that's what he
said about you and you both live in a
town where such most relationships and
friendships are transactional but you
both say that friendship trumps
everything including politics from your
point of view what does this mean to you
you know we get to pick our friends we
get to pick our family although I don't
want my family getting offended I love
my family but we get to pick our friends
and I think other than family the
greatest subunit our culture has its
relationship and friendships and you
know for me it does transcend politics
which is one reason I recommended him
for the US and and not myself well part
of that was selfishness I didn't want to
be in the US Senate and have to run
statewide I didn't want to be in a
Republican primary but it's also I think
having the self-awareness of knowing
that he's a lot better than I am at some
things including I don't wanna say
politics because I doesn't sound like a
compliment although I mean it it's one
he's better at it than I am so there is
no rivalry the only argument we had
writing this book was my insistence that
his name go first because he's not a
state sentence by the way congressman
let me ask you this though you talk
about his attributes in the most glowing
way you talk about his restraint his
humility and and all of those qualities
that come from the fact that you are
both Christians then there's politics
where those and we've talked about it
this morning those don't exist the best
example of a great politician today is
Donald Trump does he embody any of those
attributes you ascribe to the
senator you know John I think politics
is it's been divisive the whole time
I've been in DC I think it's probably
getting worse so politics to me is
inherently divisive and it's one reason
I'm leaving
but the divisiveness didn't start with
Donald Trump it's existed from the from
the first day politics is all about
winning and I don't think there's any
other relationship we have in life where
our sole goal is to win by whatever
means that's why I wonder senator if
these two things are incompatible if you
want to win by all costs and then if
you're gonna be the kind of person that
the congressman described you as being
well I love trade because he is
integrity is unquestioned what I would
say about my passion for politics is
it's a mission I don't care about the
office I hold I don't care about the
title I have I was given a second chance
by this country I was given a second
chance by voters I was the guy that was
flunking out of high school when you
feel world geography and civics study
involved yes
you don't necessarily go into politics
but the reality of it was that my
teachers my mother my mentor all saw
something in me that I could not see in
myself and one of the reasons why I'm
excited about unified in my path in
politics is because hope is necessary in
a toxic world the polarization in this
country must be bridged so that we are
one nation one American family focused
on ways to get back to a position of
truth honesty and believing that
American exceptionalism is alive and
well and you can find that in unifying
and you're the party of free markets
right in this country the Republican
Party we don't really have presidents in
the past speaking out and lashing out at
specific companies we hear the president
now the past few days for the past year
has been lashing out against Amazon Jeff
Bezos in particular obviously we know
Jeff Bezos also owns the Washington Post
it's been reported that Trump has told
advisers he believes Jeff Bezos is using
the Washington Post as a political
weapon do you see congressman any signs
that the president that Jeff Bezos is
using the Washington Post as a political
weapon
I don't read the post enough to be able
to answer that question honestly I will
tell you this and I believe this I don't
mean if
to anyone in your line of work anymore
they're not doing in my line of work I
think conflict cells and and I think
contrast is good and it's healthy
conflict cells and there are times when
I will look at the at the webpage on the
Washington Post and almost every
editorial almost every opinion that's
different from new this but almost every
editorial if you're a Republican they're
hard to read the headline so politics is
as divisive now I think as it's ever
been in our country it's one reason I'm
getting out and it's one reason that we
wrote the book unified if if people will
sit down and have a conversation with
each other which quite frankly we do
privately in Washington we don't want
you all to know that but but we get
along really well privately we should
know that but I think the reason you
don't know it is the primary system is
set up where you got a guy I don't want
to get him in trouble so Joey I'm sorry
but but but but but for Joey Kennedy be
threatened with the primary because he
attended the inauguration he may have
his own inauguration one day he said
family members with inauguration but if
you're gonna be threatened with a
primary or if I have to stop and think
about whether or not the compliment a
Democrat when I'm on a talk show talk
show a radio talk show then that's a
pretty toxic environment we're at well
listen you all left us with a lot to
think about you say politics won't
change the condition of the country but
changing the human heart will unified is
certainly that congratulations to you
both
thank you we see the book team put it
down a lawyer
Congress
I don't know what he did in civics but
he's doing here's what to do in sale